when people ask me about breaking up
with girls is you know i've
what you have to do when it's not
working with a girl is
wish them luck
to give them the best of luck wish them
luck
walk away and don't look back
and you're still going to get those
emotions those things are still going to
hit you but walk away and don't look
back and there's two reasons for that
number one
if there's any chance
that it's going to work out
the best possible way for you to get it
to work out is by walking away by
wishing them look walk away and don't
look back that's the best way how so
because if there is something there
then
she will let you know eventually
and if there's nothing there
you're gonna know that too because
you're never here hear from her again
that's fine
the protocol for getting her back
is to walk away and don't look back
that's the protocol is to move on
the protocol if she doesn't want you
back is to walk away and don't look back
so i look and i know it's hard
but
you'll you'll get some of those waves
but those waves will become less
frequent and they'll become less
powerful and eventually you can move on
and then you know the last thing i'll
say about this is in both these
scenarios is remember but don't dwell
so you got you look you remember your
friends you honor your friends you
remember what they gave you what they
taught you what you learned from them
what was great about them what you miss
about them you remember all those things
but you don't dwell in the past and and
dwell on those thoughts and dwell on the
loss all the time because that's not
healthy either and it's not gonna help
you it's not what your friend would want
you to do anyways
i like the insight around when you are
going through grief
and then you stop
the sense of guilt that comes through
because you feel
now somehow that you're
doing a disservice to their memory like
you didn't really care
or something like that yeah
it helps to
you know it helps to write about
what what i've told people to do is
write that personal letter
and tell them what you loved about them
what you're going to miss about them how
you felt about them what you regret you
write all that stuff in a letter put an
envelope bring it to their grave and put
it there
and and that will help you process as
well i mean i've
unfortunately or fortunately i've i've
given a bunch of eulogies for friends
that i've lost and
in the beginning i didn't really
recognize that that's a way of healing
but
certainly writing down your emotions
your feelings what you're going to miss
what you loved about them is very
therapeutic and it's very good and so
that's another thing i recommend is you
write that stuff down and and you
you bring it to him
that's another petersonism from his
rules for life he says if memories still
make you cry write them down
yeah
that's a you know i talk a lot about
being able to detach from your emotions
and it's very important well when you
write something down you are
literally detaching from those thoughts
because they're going out on a piece of
paper that then you can see
so it's a very important thing to do to
write down
if there's emotions that you have to
deal with write down and i just like to
give someone some kind of an objective
so instead of just saying write down the
emotions no here's write that person
tell them and that will kind of be like
a writing prompt
to get you to write the right things
about that situation what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you